[Music]
it is
[Applause]
[Music]
I want to see comos in the chat because
we have the emotes now so let's get
after it
[__] bread
um yeah he uh let me read this real
quick uh half hammer or is that
stuttering uh Throw Mama From uh Throw
Mama From the train no uh forever two
wheels I know the merch break the group
to join with zumac I knew six years ago
ROTC wouldn't last and I love to see all
the Como emojis in the chat thank you
that's that would be the best little bit
like when something ends up to like 10
15 years and you go I [__] called it
I knew it I told you like you said 10
years I knew Ron and Fest was over Fest
died
that's right
I knew it
uh rip Fest
um yes
can it be fixed
yes the Supreme Court is broken that's
what he's talking about
in full
I'm not sure but I can take you through
what the law is he's gonna fix the
Supreme Court Kris Cuomo dumbest Guido
that's ever been
I don't it's gonna fix the Supreme Court
on his YouTube show I wouldn't trust you
to go in and fix a retail stores
operations no
is what the policies are but most
importantly what the problems are and
here's my take the number one problem
can absolutely be fixed it's not about
having the ability it's about whether or
not we have the will
shomo project
[Music]
in this intro him like shopping
why would we need more people tweeting
that at him
we really need more people to I want
people to keep tweeting this Chris Cuomo
until he changes his intro for us he
will he'll change it too yeah
I'm Chris Cuomo thank you for joining me
for another episode of change everything
makes it worse because it's called a
traumosexual hour
episode of the Chris Cuomo project where
I'm breaking down some of this he's
breaking it down the sticky stuff that's
troubling us in our society come
appreciate you following subscribing
being a critical thinker being a free
agent where you know what there's not
enough busy [__] happening on the screen
holy [__] how many logos and overlays
are we gonna get I love that we put all
this work on our shirts and they're
really nice and they're [__] all the
Arts amazing and Chris Cuomo just writes
the text free agent and it still sells
it for the same price that we sell our
shirt which is [__] [__] your
independence by getting your merch but
also by getting away from the parties
because if you're going to be a critical
thinker you can't just be a packer yeah
who you voting for next election
they call me independent Chris yeah
you're gonna you're gonna vote for
[__] the libertarian party [__] out
of here it follows people because that's
your team okay and that takes us to this
also Chris traps are lacking bro shrugs
gotta do those shrugs Supreme Court we
have salad [__] them that would honestly
[__] him up like things like him like
that if you were to criticize a little
tiny thing about him and be like what do
you mean what do you mean I [__] do
more than you that's for [__] choice
you see my 100 pound dumbbell all right
you look great you calves are a little
smaller you know what I mean it's just
like wait what several obvious issues
okay uh in no particular order but I'll
put the one that matters to me last one
they can be there forever
two they don't have to well no I mean
eventually they have to die yeah
unless you're like [__] heads in jars
like in Futurama Supreme Court yes I
think [__] chief justice Snoop Dogg
was on a head and a chart in the future
um Plato's Punk Nixon 71 what day is it
to tell us enough about what conflicts
and financial Arrangements that they
have and three
there is this Fugazi
for gays
oh I still gotta be a thousand I can't
help it I'm surprised he didn't do this
while he was saying it he did it all
over the table
kind of like he helped his brother when
he was at CNN yeah
that they are above politics and never
have to give any indication of how they
feel about anything even when
confronting the Senate body that is
supposed to give advise and consent so
you're saying it shouldn't be
politicized but we should ask them
political questions yes
genius so that we because we can't stop
it from being politicized but we can
stop people we disagree with politically
correct okay that makes sense all right
it just sounds like you're sad because
you're losing like no no honestly if the
numbers were the other way if there was
more liberal justices
he'd be like this system is perfect you
saw the founder fathers in town Benjamin
Franklin I'm actually related to
Benjamin do you know that benjam
Benjamin Franklin dude there's still a
really loud vocal movement of people
that want to like double the [__]
justices and [__] oh yeah and don't
think they won't do it they'll try
to the president's nominee Choice how do
they do that when they don't know a damn
thing about the people now the real
answer to that last point is they do
know and they know what they want and
they know what they like and both sides
play this game which is why we see it
play out the same way every time
somebody new is selected so much so yeah
that way Brett Kavanaugh has been such a
[__] Paragon of right-wing values
yeah very good point yes exactly and
when these men and women get on the
court they vote with the party's
interest that put them there so often
that when they don't you know Justice
Kennedy is not no hold on a second
that's not necessary so I will agree
there's hard lines like you know Ruth
Bader and Clarence Thomas they are very
they were you know she's dead good and
he's definitely more hardlined with the
party in terms of that but there's
there's moderate Justice there's always
been moderate justices
yeah yeah what's her name Amy Winehouse
yeah Amy Winehouse I don't know her name
now she gets them coffee right that's
her job the new black one too right only
because she's the junior one not the
because she's what's the new one's name
a Katie wakanda what's the new black
one's name
do me a favor Fergie Google chief
justice Baba booba I believe it's chief
justice Saba Simba or do you do just to
be safe do chief justice click noises
see what comes up just click into your
[__] microphone yeah please thank you
here's what search Chief Justice
Clarence Thomas's worst nightmare a
black woman
Search for Chief Justice and then make a
bunch of Kamala noises yeah see what
happens
we know
scotus is an easy legal wall wakanda
Brown thank you it's wakanda Brown look
for you okay you just Google section uh
article three section one now it's very
interesting the Constitution only
creates in and of itself the Supreme
Court did you know that yes yeah it's
like article three bro is this like
third grade well I feel like I'm in
third grade right we know what that does
so the government's got three branches
oh there we go so you got the
legislation you got the executive and
then you got the post office I think
that's the post office and then there's
the post office so there's four really
if you think about it and then NASA but
that's like its own but it's space so it
doesn't count on Earth yeah and it's
NASA like the CIA they're not allowed to
operate on U.S soil he's so stupid it's
a [__]
the Constitution gives Congress the
ability to con create all lower courts
it's interesting why does the president
get to he's not only reading and they're
fundamentally select a Supreme Court
Judge you're reading you're reading the
prep book that I got in eighth grade for
midterms and you're like that's
fascinating
he didn't flip the page to checks and
balances oh no oh my God it's just like
[__] Civics 101 you forget it's
something Chris Cuomo thinks readings
for [__]
half Hammer Cuomo says so many words to
convey zero message or pertinent
information it is a lot of gobbledygook
huh Hey listen the only thing right now
listen the only thing I read is the
numbers on the plates
and I'm doing doing four on each side
how's that sound
We're Not Gonna pack the court but we're
gonna pack my bar
and that have been left did you see
their little uh film trick with the the
mjf Adam Cole thing which we're at the
gym together oh yeah yeah they did the
little they [__] zoned in so you
couldn't see you know what yeah
to the body Hamilton made a very
interesting case in the Articles of
Confederation one man's perspective
that's not Hamel Hamilton Hamilton's a
Puerto Rican guy that sings I've seen
the [__] that is true he was and he was
originally from Washington Heist
it was better than a bodies because of
the varied interests you know it reminds
me of the joke what is a zebra
it's a mulatto horse that's what we
called it in my house
uh Chris I think it's pronounced zebra
thank you and the problem with zebras is
it doesn't matter if it's 50 50 black or
white they're always going to identify
with the black stripes
that's why they live in Africa
a horse made by committee
okay
so Hamilton believed that it was better
to have the fruit of one mind but you
got to question that really with
something as important as a Supreme
Court Justice now no instead we should
do is we should have it be even worse
and let everyone kind of vote that way
we get [__] like I said chief justice
[__] Snoop Dogg
the shizzle my nizzle no I'm fired why
are there only nine
is this social studies he's like a 10
year old
why is there only nine why not ten he's
pretending he's independent and both
sides are crazy but what he's doing he's
pushing for packing the court when he
says why are there only nine that's not
in the Constitution ah
guidos Dom Guido's trying to sound smart
I think it's a kink of mine because I
love it so much I love it so much so
there is an ability to control where'd
that come from well just like FDR
spooked Congress
he's not the one that nominated Clarence
Thomas how come we kicked off YouTube
yeah when I say spooked Sage [__]
haven't uh haven't chat GPD Como in a
white uh sent it to your Twitter DMS
I'll check it out uh both houses uh with
wanting to limit how many terms the
president could have is he went for four
he also tried to pack the court
which also spooked his own party so they
were able to put a restriction in place
now
remember this
the Supreme Court is unique in that it's
like a regular court but with guacamole
and sour cream
but just a dollop because it's all empty
calories it is the ultimate form of
reviewing laws treaties in the
Constitution itself
what's interesting is that what the
Supreme Court seems to do most is what
the [__] in his tablet he's reading this
off of this happen of course yeah he's a
[__] he's an idiot
review the Constitution at least he's
reading yeah good point he's doing the
best he can or what they call coming
along with his finger like a child
the only way he knows how
so when Hamilton was talking about the
Constitution institutional questions
that arise in
legislation now interestingly that is
not an enumerated power
word of the day calendar
power in the Constitution power is the
word yeah
that was given by judicial decision by
the Supreme Court itself in 1803 and of
course the very famous case of Marbury
versus Madison that gave us the
principle of judicial review isn't that
interesting
and not given the power to do in the
Constitution itself now man this is some
really in-depth [__] what are we going
to do next week Read To Kill a
Mockingbird you [__]
this [__] nice curriculum [__]
feed Lord of the Flies but he said it
was too scary
a fact
he's like he's like he's like a high
school like substitute teacher in
history class when he comes in and it's
like he can't just teach you the
curriculum because he doesn't know where
the last teacher left off so he just
like so let's talk about Supreme Court
fascinating stuff and he doesn't know he
he goes what do you guys think about it
Miss K left her lesson plan in the desk
[__]
hey who said that
I did you're
you know if anybody respected me to
school you'll be in big trouble
did did you ever treat a substitute
teacher well unless it was a hot chick
no no unless it was a hot chick it was
like it was a hot chick in her 20s you
were always nice and then we treated her
poorly but it was in a totally different
way yo well good point
good point
small businessmen lone wolves
this is a live raid we gotta find
efficiencies that's why I believe in
look at his hat
Lone Wolf see free agent wasn't taken
off right
is that one of those Patch hats yeah
d.com
I want you to look at something I want
you to look in doing his library look at
the reflection behind them you can see
him holding his phone this is a
professional Library yes okay good we
got too much stuff to do to be hopping
from site to site and interacting in
different ways at different times
indeed.com allows you to attract and
interview and vet and you have to do
this right after cardio
yeah that's when his mind is says right
he does fasted cardio so his mind is
fresh uh also don't give a [__] about
this then why should we have to give a
[__] about this Chris
uh indeed indeed is also the number of
speaking of scammers and [__] indeed
it's the one of the number one sites
that scammers use to send like fake oh
we have a job for you yeah people yeah
same place right now they want to poke
me up I mean unless you want us to do
libraries and it's like the best safest
site whatever yeah it's awesome because
they're trying to help my business uh
you get a 75 dollar credit if you go to
indeed.com
Chris C he does his library's walking
around so you can see his beautiful
property and it'll be a boost is there
anything better than a website that's
like Hey we're gonna help you get a job
but you got to pay us
yeah I know it's the best hiring
live read without eye contact site three
million business if Thomas Murphy was
doing a live read he's reading it he was
looking down at the notes.com oh my God
obviously they're doing something right
all right we saw your problem is they're
creating a fish that's what he's doing
right he's showing off his property for
small businesses
so we got too much coming at us today
hey I'm not gonna keep this boat dock
exit for nothing
I need somebody I need something to pay
for that all right we're done the rest
is him it's basically the same thing I'm
saying a lot of words with no actual
information
um he's pretty stupid